when I was a kid I loved to Bill marvels
and I had a very active fantasy life I
was an only child and my family moved
around a lot so I didn't have not
because I was a bad boy but I didn't
have a lot of friends so I had a lot of
time to imagine worlds and universes of
my own and as I got older the marvels
got more sophisticated and I love movies
and suddenly it was just seemed like a
natural mill to go into creating worlds
for movies and and I had you know a
couple of the tools I you know I picked
up sketching along the way I picked up a
love for architecture and art and it all
seemed to come together and it's the
perfect place for me I think there's
always well what's the difference
between a production designer and a set
designer or what's the difference
between a production designer and an art
director or what's the difference
between a production designer and a set
this set decorator designer or whatever
term they come up with I think the
biggest misconceptions are nobody quite
knows the amount of effort that goes
into creating the backgrounds for a
movie and they and and in an odd way
that's a compliment to the great craft
that we practice which is they they feel
like well you know that looks perfectly
appropriate to whatever's going on in
the movie so it must have just found it
it's perfect and ultimately that's what
we really want for for any movie we work
on is for the general audience to not be
able to imagine that it could take place
anywhere else because it's so
appropriate and and whatever is in the
background always guides you back to the
story guys you back to the thematic
material back to the plot back to the
characters and always resonates with
whatever they're doing production design
has changed over the years and yet it
hasn't technology has certainly changed
a lot of the techniques but when one
studies the people who were forging the
path for production design back at the
turn of the last century and into the
20s and the 30s and and creating
different kinds of settings that were
more and more naturalistic as the
equipment got a little bit more flexible
and as the artistry got more
as the artistry got more artistic some
of the techniques that were evolved in
the 30s for instance and the 20s are
basically still the same techniques that
we have now that we use now only we use
computers instead of little miniatures
or glass shots or different things but
ultimately the thing that hasn't changed
is that it's an image image driven art
it the each image on the screen forwards
the story and pulls the pose the
listener pulls the audience in to the
world of the story and and that hasn't
changed whereas in the in the 30s you
would have a foreground constructed
space and perhaps miniatures or some
kind of ambien middle ground and then
you would have a flat painted backdrop
in the background now we use computer
technology to create either computer
match shots or three-dimensional match
shots we make it seem more real but it's
the same technique and and really what
has had to evolve for art directors and
for production designers is that we've
had to know what the not only what the
uses of these new techniques are and
what their limitations are but we also
have to know how to blend them and and
use a live action when necessary in
certain limited ways so that it will
seamlessly blend into whatever technique
it is we're using to extend or create
that world
you